they're nuts here was reaction this book
just out today amazon.com Hannity calm
bookstores everywhere perfect title
triggered how the left thrives on hate
and wants to silent us he's also the
executive vice president at the Trump
Organization Donald Trump jr. okay I'll
take the bait I heard your dad what
would happen if he was the vice
president he shook down and leveraged
the billion taxpayer dollars in a quid
pro quo Joe and you were getting paid
millions for no experience obviously
it'd be fine Sean I took an unsolicited
phone call when we were in a campaign
mode as a private citizen
unsolicited and I've done thirty hours
of testimony in front of the House and
the Senate
I've had all of those same journalists
say that I committed treason on live
television for years but hunter Biden no
smoke even with the John Solomon stuff
coming out it's good to see it but you
think that if I took a 20-minute meeting
from an unsolicited phone call that
merited thirty hours of testimony in
front of the House and the Senate
with everyone basically the only rule
that trying to get you for perjury you
think hunter Biden should at least go
and maybe do something I thought Rand
Paul nailed it out of the park tonight
at the rally when he said just that it's
time and the American people are sick of
this Sean okay I love the word triggered
the day and it's the perfect word and
I'm reading a book it's it's
extraordinarily well done I give you a
lot of credit and you and you're gonna
be all over the country and you can go
to wherever your website is and and
people can go see you you but here's the
thing you know think of Nicholas Sandman
let go Sammy
he wears a mag ahead you neither you or
I would shows much restraint as Nicholas
Sandman would did in that situation
not even close that crap and nor would
you the kid did it right god bless he's
gonna be a billionaire it might be
richer than your dad at the end of this
well listen without question I mean this
is the stuff that I get into in the book
I mean I literally go through at length
the hypocrisy of the media this shadow
banning from you know there's social
justice warriors and the social media
companies that are doing whatever they
can to prevent
that message from getting out to stymie
the message of success of victory of
all-time low unemployment numbers of
all-time high stock market numbers every
aspect of this economy is churning and
then you see the media literally trying
so hard just to destroy that trying so
hard to try to discredit it they're
literally trying to turn the economy and
so you know for years people said dawn
maybe you should write the business book
I said now that you know my dad has that
totally covered but when you've been
through what I've been through for the
last few years has the number two target
of the Muller hoax of that joke Jared
gave you a little run for your money and
and I've been Baron gave you a run for
the money you even attack in Europe
that's the whole point I mean your
brother I get to watch the media
personalities talk about hunter Biden's
off limits because it's family if hunter
Biden is a 50 year old corrupt
businessman with no business being on
any of those boards is off limits
thirteen year old bear and Trump should
be off-limits I certainly wasn't
off-limits for obviously a lot less with
a lot less smoke and when we weren't
actually even in power and that's the
sickness that's there I mean that's why
I did this book that's why we get into
detail and it gives me a real
opportunity to go into long-form I mean
there's only so much you can do in an
interview whether it's here radio or
otherwise but it allows me to take 300
pages to go through in detail of all of
this stuff they can go to triggered book
calm they can check out all the places
we're gonna be around the country in New
York in Florida in California in Texas
where we're gonna do stops and get to
see these people who have been so
awesome and I mean the book is literally
dedicated Shawn I think you'll
appreciate this a deploy the deplorable
because those are the people that he's
stuck with us from moment one and if bid
will t you are there to if I get it
you're smelly i smelly Walmart shopper
Costco shopper Target shopper and I
clink to God in heaven I do I believe in
the Second Amendment Bible and my
religion I am guilty as charged
and those are the throw that I've shown
when you look and reelect your debt
let's say they impeach him not getting
convicted Willie Browns right then the
American people look I was in Chicago in
Detroit this weekend they are pissed
they're sick of this three years
never-ending lies conspiracy theories
another hoax everyone I met they're fed
up seems like they'll crawl over broken
glass to get to the polls on Election
Day well they should be shown and you
see it and everyone knows this
impeachment inquiry it started on
November 9th 2016 ok the Washington Post
wrote their first up at 19 minutes after
he took office in January of 2017 making
it the case for impeachment this has
been going on forever it's holy semi
montage because they can't accept that
he won this election that he beat the
anointed one Hillary Clinton who in all
fairness let's face it had no business
ever running this country he's done a
great job well he's done a great press
identity in coming Sean the book we'll
put it up again it's called triggered
now out in bookstores everywhere Hannity
com amazon.com Don jr. will see on the
road and as always thanks for being with
us Congrats on the book